bonsoir diagonale actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs pleins
feux sur mes cahiers loi kasparov
cramique à nantes sont bien là mais
shirov aussi shirov également puisque le
jeune russe fire of the board comme on
l'appelle est en tête du tournoi avec
quatre points sur cinq après cinq
parties
donc résultat tout à fait exceptionnelle
pour ce joueur qui finalement était le
moins bien loti des quatre premiers à
noter qu'il ya beaucoup de surprises
dans ce tournoi notamment morose et vici
et la [ __ ] art déco qui est en bas enfin
on va commenter tout ça avec plus de
détails il ya moi évidemment voulu
tourner à être très longue puisqu'il
dure trois semaines on a largement le
temps de tout voir tout ce qu'il y aura
13 ronde en tout il peut tout se passer
un très bon d'effectivement saison pour
l'instant on a fait cinq parties ça veut
donc dire qu'on est presque à la moitié
du tournoi alexei shirov en tête c'est
quand même un événement
alors on reviendra en fin de mission sur
un autre événement aussi c'est la
victoire des tubes accro à égalité les
premiers ex-aequo tournal linares qui
était un assez fort européenne s'est pas
souvent que etienne lacour des open et
la classe quand même place enfin on ne
commentera plus tard mais effectivement
il a quand même eu un début très
difficile puisqu'il a commencé avec deux
points sur quatre le petit etienne et il
est revenu avec ses nuits sur 7
pas mal alors bien sûr mécanisée alors
on peut dire encore une fois que
kasparov a essayé d'expliquer qu'il
avait raté des gains oui alors
effectivement c'est là c'est la blague
qui circule sur internet en ce moment
chaque fois qu à se renflouer une partie
en direct et qu'il a l'air bien et qu'il
ne gagne pas et bien tout le monde
s'exclame on verra encore demain sur
kasparov chaise puisque c'est son site
personnel entre guillemets
combien de gains il a raté puisqu'il va
encore se plaindre et râler sur tous les
toits effectivement kasparov c'est sa
réputation
il aime bien montrer qu'il était gagnant
et qu'il a raté le gain
et se lamenter c'est un peu le mur des
lamentations ce site skysports.com alors
c'est mais c'est toujours contre le mc
contre huk radnic donc il avait son
peut-être d'ailleurs une position
gagnante c'est possible mais rien n'est
sûr parce que kramnik à chaque fois même
avec un pool - elle va faire nul
finalement assez tranquille oui il ya
effectivement il affrontements phare
kasparov contre gravelines kasparov
avait les blancs partie très
intéressante puisque c'était une fois de
plus une défense de berlin donc la
fameuse berlinoise que kasparov a eu
tant de mal à passer
les catalans on va pas c'est qu'il n'a
toujours pas passé pourquoi eh bien on
se le demande encore en tout cas
kasparov dans ses commentaires expliqué
qu' on arrivait dans une structure
typiquement berlinoise mais que c'était
à priori égal simplement il ya eu des
fautes réciproque et ensuite kasparov
s'est retrouvé mieux et n'a pas gagné
hélas pas gagner alors il aurait
peut-être pu aussi expliqué comment il
aurait pu perdre puisque alain de cette
voie lui a failli battre on peut lire 1
c'est avoir une partie très tendue et ça
s'est joué à une demi faute près en à
dire ouais c'était vraiment une partie
extrêmement compliqué à nantes avait les
noirs dans qu'est ce que tu avais encore
les blancs entre contre vichy manhattan
allende enfin une fois de plus on serait
on tenté de dire puisqu'il a les blancs
contre tout l'effort joueurs y compris
qu'entre shirov ouais donc ça c'est
plutôt un bon apparemment pour garry
kasparov quoique ça se discute mais en
tout cas cette partie caspar fans en
était très chaude puisque ananda a donné
un fou dans le début dans une espagnole
il a donné la terre de feu
volontairement
ensuite il a trouvé du contre jeu très
précisément kasparov avait l'air mieux
il était probalement mieux donc c'est
une fois de plus scandalisé sur son site
comme quoi il était beaucoup mieux
mouais mais finalement c'est quand même
un homme qui après les complications
réussi à revenir à tirer son épingle du
jeu et qui rate un petit détail à la fin
ce qui fait que la partie s'achève par
la nulle ouais alors donc pour l'instant
donc en tête c'est shirov qui lui donc
aligne deux victoires contre une seule
au suivant c'est ça je le tente d'un an
chez rosa 3 victoires en 3 retenu est le
suivant 1
oui
par contre il n'a pas encore joué contre
les contrôles aient promis
non effectivement il n'a pas joué contre
kasparov ni contre il a joué contre
personne tout simplement le jeu contre
personne alors et jean va vite
évidemment voir aujourd'hui
la partie enfin une des parties
intéressantes c'est notamment la partie
anand tibia kof
mais on va aussi revenir sur d'autres
partis notamment une très beau matt de
maurs et mende et vite mais on va
rappeler surtout que la semaine
prochaine on fait un spécial vehicles et
avec
image à la clé et interviews images et
interviews alors effectivement nous
irons avec andy l'équipe de diagonale
ira avec jean-luc chavanon qui donc un
expert en interview percutante sait on
peut l'appeler le ardisson diagonale
donc jean-luc chavanon va aller chercher
des infos qu'on ne trouve pas ailleurs
c'est un peu c'est assez vendeur mais
c'est le but
donc on verra bien en tout cas a priori
des interviews choc des images
intéressantes
ouais c'est toujours un plaisir de voir
ce tournoi ce grand hall la soupe aux
haricots voire même la soupe aux petits
pois puisque c'est la tradition là bas
donc il y aura tout ça dans le reportage
de la semaine prochaine effectivement
ceux des femmes on détaille le
classement
tout de suite non on va y revenir après
la partie peut être on va pour les
détails du rouge pas quand tu veux on
peut le classer maintenant avec la
sous-location maintenant alors des en
premier chez rough oignies quatre points
sur sur scène qu donc c'est pas mal
c'est impressionnant belle partie compte
e-mail hier avec ces chiffres forment
donc deuxièmes à égalité on retrouve
kasparov cramique est morose et leach
alors là voilà morose et beach il faut
quand même le signaler
un départ on ne l'attendait pas on ne
l'attendait pas à ce niveau là plus de
c'est pas mal faut se rappeler comment
zellidja fait aussi une très bon départ
à sarajevo
impuissant il était donc si dans les
premiers il s'est écroulé à la fin c'est
sur les gens a perdu 3 2 38 ou quelque
chose comme ça qu'est ce qu'il tient la
distance aussi c'est ça ça sera à voir
où effectivement ces sportifs en tout
cas on peut rappeler comme qui a eu un
début percutant de garry kasparov
puisqu'il a commencé par une victoire en
25 ou contre fedorov
ouais donc avec les noirs donc fedorov
est un bon joueur kasparov a gagné 25
watts les noirs tout à fait
exceptionnelle deuxième partie il gagne
encore facilement avec les noirs contre
tibia coffre ouais donc kasparov
vraiment à enchaîner les victoires à
jouer son rôle des crasses patates et on
le voyait vraiment sur un nuage dans ce
tournoi il a été freinée il a été freiné
par anne en déclin de 10 pour les autres
mines facilement et images alors ensuite
derrière on retrouve des joueurs qui
n'ont qui ont pas perdu
et qui ont gagné une fois c'est adams et
allende à nantes toujours là en
embuscade façon rien n'est fait c'est
simplement le départ mais bon il ya un
petit retard quand même attention ça
voyez votre retard sur le premier ça
commence à faire beaucoup 5 juan mauvais
départ pour annoncer il faut il faut le
dire quand même il a fait quatre nuls un
gain s'est pas beaucoup il nous a
habitués quand même à être plus
percutant que ça à noter que le nombre
ne joue pas quand ils allaient noir
c'est à dire il laisse aller ils
espèrent la nuit à noter aussi canal
fait un très fort championnat du monde
qui s'est terminée quand même fin
décembre on est peut-être le légère
décompression voilà juste 15 jours pour
se remettre pas facile alors que
qu'est-ce qu'on fait cramique en ce sens
opposé pendant deux mois ça c'est
important suivi ensuite par ivantchouk
timan à 2,5
et enfin on va retrouver les coteaux pas
l'os et vendredi avec deux alors grosse
contre-performance de peter l'écho
stéphane pour l'instant deux points sur
cinq c'est pas du tout à la hauteur de
ce qu'on espérait de ce joueur qui a
raté son championnat du monde fis des il
était soit disant malade c'est probable
d'ailleurs en étant éliminé par qualif
mano au deuxième tour enfin en troisième
et ici c'est pas brillant deux sur cinq
c'est un mauvais début il a perdu
également le match entre chronique en
semi rapide
il joue beaucoup et mauvaises réussite
d'hôpital et qu en ce moment alors
peut-être il est toujours malade
puisqu'il était malade peut-être un
virus persistant peut-être mieux space
systems est en fait on va retrouver en
dernière position fedorov epic est avec
un point et demi et infantile via qu'aux
femmes 0,5
c'est pas beaucoup s'est pas posé
beaucoup mais c'est pas facile de
marquer des points dans ce tournant là
un bi poin sur cinq c'est très peu a
noté ctive yaakov avec un gagner le
tournoi b l'année dernière c'est là
qu'on mesure quand même la différence de
niveau qu'il ya entre les grands maîtres
conventionnel et le top niveau mondial
ouais tout à fait alors on va voir tout
de suite cette partie entre à nantes
justement est-il yaakov un bon mais tu y
vas kof a perdu me l'a fait de belle
partie en défense et en médecine si les
bienfaits produit en fait des prix de
beauté voilà il l'a promis il fait il a
participé au prix de voter ces
saloperies le beau temps dans le mon
corps en fait donc annonce à les blancs
le coup eux deux quatre m'ont ils jouent
toujours s'agit maintenant d'un an d'ici
s'était essayé à des cats mais il
préfère largement le pion roy steve
yaakov lui c'est un adepte de la
cécilienne dragon qu'on n'a pas beaucoup
commenté stéphane je pense pas qu'on en
ait commenté un petit peu un petit peu
quand même hein on en a parlé un petit
peu on va en voir revoir un mois
expliqué pourquoi on appelle ça le dire
le droit
donc c'est une sicilienne ouverte
puisqu'on joue cavalier f3 la ccnm fermé
c'est évidemment cavalli c3 ce qui
caractérise le terme ouvert c'est que
les blanches ont très vite d2 d4 donc
qui ouvre le centre en installant ce duo
de pions permettant la sortie des fous
bon ça c'est très bien et en même temps
il ya un échange de pions au centre donc
lyon prend des quatre cavaliers prend
des 4 on est dans la cécilienne va
prendre variantes et la g6 et si ce
n'est le meilleur du dragon voilà ce à
deux coups du dragon ne joue pas tout à
fait cet ordre de coups parce que les
nuls et blancs peuvent peut-être joué
ces quatre là avec une variante un peu
différente
oui
mais c'est effectivement on va retrouver
un homme va transposer finalement dans
la riante traditionnel oui oui tout à
fait enfin c'est une drague on dit
accélérer la dragon normal se passe pas
comme ça puisque on sort pas tout de
suite le camion c6
il ya des avantages et des inconvénients
effectivement je ne suis pas
complètement sûr de ça mais je crois que
les banques peuvent jouer ces cas précis
on peut toujours s'en avec donc un auto
de maroci en perspective et par contre
pour transposer dans la vente normal
c'est un peu plus délicat mais ici les
deux joueurs étaient d'accord pour y
aller qu'avec ces trois fous g7 où j'ai
cette fouille 3 voilà lequel est en jce
en fait 1 1 2 continue le développement
normal de lavera gong comme si les noirs
avaient joué les coups dans le bon ordre
oui cavalière six canettes six premières
menaces positionnelle cavaler g4 qui
donc d'ici attaquerait le fouet trois
ans le bressan c'est pas possible il ya
quand même la dame
ah oui d'accord il sent que c'est chaud
sécheresse est choquée g4 qui attaquent
le fou avec déstabilisation du centre
bell adam la dame contrôle info expliqué
quand il faut que à terme contrôler la
dame contrôle mais il avait envie
reprendre le cavalier c'est le cas ils
au centre qui serait en prise voilà par
le vent fou et par lequel pas le carnet
voilà à noter bon alors là il ya bien
des choses mais donc ça empêche quand
même les blancs de jouer le coup qu'ils
auraient voulu jouer dans cette position
stéphane le ku'damm d2 puisque sur des
deux il y aura cette fois-ci vraiment
magique moyens plus serein et en plus
sera pas un prix cette fois donc c'est
quatre fous ces quatre voilà et ça
empêche aussi à notre coût possible pour
une marque qui était le coup d'essai de
dessin nuit oui alors effectivement il
ya une autre stratégie pour les blancs
qui consiste à ne pas mettre le france
et 4 qui a lieu dans la dragon normal
c'est à dire quand les noirs ont
commencé par jouer 17 des six et non pas
qu'elle nécessiterait donc ça c'est une
position différente j'imaginais que
cavalier soit encore sur sa case de
départ je vais enlever le reste stefan
wess que ça nous perturbe
si le cavalier ces six étaient encore
sur la classe b vite et l'option noir
était sur la case des six il y aurait
des petites différences et les blancs
ici ne préférerais ne pas mettre le feu
sur un car ces 4 ca c
oui et en fait là ils sont imposées 2 le
maître puisque sinon des noirs jours et
17 des 50 un seul coup ouais donc pas
tant qu'avant-centre finalement avec une
bonne position avec une bonne position
donc issifou c4 l'idée de ce coup c'est
d'empêcher les noirs de jouer c'est
certain désarroi ya pas que ça aussi ça
tape sur le pion à vii 1 ça c'est la
deuxième idée c'est l'idée d' attaque
mais c'est avant tout un coup de défense
dans cette position s'était fait mal à
une position petit rock du rock four b3
voilà en général même une fois que le
faussaire atteint 6,4 on met souvent
souci de classe b 3 parce qu'il est bien
protégé par ses pions oui sinon il reste
se faire attaquer assez vite
alors là je crois stéphane donc le tibia
kof a joué le coup 17 des six mois et y
transpose cette fois réellement dans la
dragon grandes variantes voilà alors la
dragon alors pourquoi alors on va
montrer la structure des pions noirs
voilà c'est margot l'envers finalement
si ce que le pion des six représentent
la tête à tête et les trois pions f7 g6
et h7 donc complètement à droite devant
le roi c'est le dos le dos du dragon moi
mon interprétation un peu différente
mais voilà moi je pense que tu as là les
trois pions ici ouais ce que je remets
en rouge maintenant c'est le corps et ça
c'est la lll du dragon puisque les
dragons une petite elle a noté qu'on est
plus d'ailleurs dans l'année du dragon
puisque c'était et blanc dominent et là
on est passé sous l'année du cheval non
mais si c'est une dragon normal des six
a été joué autre possibilité qu'on peut
faire grâce à cet ordre de coups de
dragon accéléré stéphane de jouer le
coup à cette a5 1 était une spécialité
du maître chilien sebastian silva
ah oui à cette a5 qui est un peu
différent et qui conduit à des positions
complexes et espère tout le temps contre
lui des arrive dans une dragons tout à
fait classique et maintenant on va voir
que les blancs donc ici doivent jouer
avec le grand roque
ouais c'est quasi indispensable donc il
joue f 3 ar s-300 double intérêt ça
protège le pion 1,4 et en plus ça
empêche les noirs de mètres de venir en
g4 et en plus ça aussi ça permet aux
bleus de jouer le coup j'ai de g4 voile
alors c'est un simple d'attaqué de
défense à la fois mais c'est moins
utiles coin un coup très utile oui qu'il
faut jouer dans cette position
à noter qu'on dit qu' on avance le pion
est trop tôt cela affaiblit le roi mais
ici c'est pas vrai puisque l blanc vont
évidemment rock et du grand côté ont
causé l'autre côté
maintenant ça va être une attaque de
pions nous sommes contre une attaque à
droite on analysera qu'on les rucks ont
effectué food et cette dame d2 alors
mais la demande des deux pourquoi parce
que d'abord est bien placé et les blancs
font souvent le couffo h6 sert le fou 3
on va souvent à 6 pour s'échanger contre
le fu g7 qui est quand même assez
puissant sur cette diagonale alors autre
idée du couffo artistes et fans ça sera
de jouer le pion h-21 h 400 que les
noirs ne se répondent pas à cette tâche
donc ça c'est un autre avantage d'avoir
bloqué d'abord en justice pour ensuite
pouvoir essayer d'ouvrir la colonne h
donc on d'ivoire typiquement devenue la
la il ya et la maintenance et l autre
avantage du coup d'être b2c évidemment
que ça permet le grand roque
oui ça permet d'en mission on va pouvoir
mettre le roi à gauche alors là les
noirs choisissent maintenant linde
oriente il y en a plusieurs possibles
ici et choisissent la variante avec
tours ces mythes pour s'est vite l'autre
coup principal c'est le ku'damm débitant
à 5 qui permet de passer la tour eiffe
sur la case céline savoir laquelle on
veut mettre en voilà donc ici via coop
mais directement la tour c c'est un
choix les deux coups existe c'est tout à
fait possible
quant au rock bien entendu ouais
tranquille maintenant on est dans la
position donc là maintenant levé leur
menace vraiment de commencé à avancer
leurs pions à droite vers le roi noir la
menace ici je pense un bon c'est le coup
h4h 4
ou alors le coup j'ai 4 on peut les
jouer dans deux heures différents
avantages de jouer quatre d'abord donc
ne s'adresse à ceux qui éventuellement
ray cette position avec les blancs c'est
que c'est plus rapide
la menace est directement de louage 5
ouais l'inconvénient c'est que ça permet
au noir de réponse le parachutage
travail ce qui freine la taxe qui freine
la table puisqu'il prend un objet de sa
coordination entend g4 mue pour
continuer la tacc donc ça c'est c'est
une question de goût du bon il ya
beaucoup de théorie on le sait il ya des
lignes très très longue un texas et la
couture c'est 8 est quand même le vieux
coup on va lire c'est le vieux coup ça
oui c'est le coût que jouer cornol
contre karpov
donc c'est donc certainement laissé à
ses vieux crc mais fisher aussi
rencontré ce coup là d'ailleurs au
passage on vous invite à regarder la
leçon dans la rubrique
c'était dans quelle rubrique qu'on a
commenté cette partie dans la rubrique
la taxe sur le roi puisque maintenant la
leçon était rubrique et canal la leçon
et vous pourrez voir la partie et la
fameuse c'est la partie karpov kornoi où
justement karpov a fait une attaque sur
laurent aime vraiment percutante et donc
c'est une partie modèle qui a été
commentée dans des donnait la leçon
grand roque le coût théorique maintenant
moderne c'est le coup cavaliers aux cinq
qui n'a pas été jouer ici on le
mentionne quand même l'idée c'est que le
cavalier vient régulièrement en c4 pour
s'échanger contre le fu blanc oui les
blancs et changent ensuite c'est
compliqué on peut aussi envisager de
jouer des cinq dans cette position
sacrifiant un pion mais c'est très très
compliqué ouvrir des lignes pour voir
des lignes c'est ici que les blancheurs
entre h4 ou g4 avec deux types d'
attaques différentes
le coût principal maintenant c'est
devenu roi bien dans cette position mais
ça c'est des considérations théoriques
complexe on va se contenter de contres
les parties sauvegardées sur un mission
cavaliers prend cavaliers des caps
alors ça alors alors alors là ça c'est
un choix on va dire curieux quand même
curieux oui et non parce que ça alors ça
c'est un show comme qui simplifie oui et
alors en fait les noirs on va voir que
les noirs ne pouvons avoir du mal du
coup à attaquer alors en permettant cet
échange en fait c'est c'est vrai mais
c'est au deuxième degré qu'il faut
prendre ce que tu as dit c'est à dire
que dans un premier temps après fou
prend des 4 on voit que les blancs n'ont
plus de cavaliers sur cette case
ouais donc les noirs peuvent lever 5 oui
deuxième remarque les blancs ne peuvent
pas je me fâche 6 c'est vrai donc on a
stoppé plus ou moins la taille des
blancs williams étant la nôtre on met de
côté le fou des quatre aussi maintenant
paralyse complètement le fou g7 qui la
pièce d'attac number one on va dire le
dragon ces atomes ou tard les noirs
sacrifice souvent lecavalier 6 par
exemple pour ouvrir la diagonale de ce
fou malade et là c'est clair que le fou
des quatre le paralyse le food et qui a
peu parlé ça c'est un bon argument mais
le l'argument le plus important dans
cette position c'est à nantes qui va
nous montrer après b5 ici on va
transformer le jeu qui pour l'instant
est une attaque réciproque chacun
attaquant de son côté - baignoire à
gauche et les blancs à droite et bien
ici non pas du tout à londres mais la
partie sur un terrain positionnelle
voilà qui joue le coup cavaliers des
cinq ça c'est très fort ça c'est un
couple alors ça c'est très très fort il
ya une menace directe positionnelle qui
de jouer le coup de prendre un rêve si
les deux sont les deux sont assez forts
sa force les noirs à reprendre avec le
pion au total et le pion des six est
perdu et puis on décide sera perdue ça
c'est une première chose
la deuxième chose donc c'est que si les
noirs et ses deux joué que 7 6 ce qui
serait une possibilité pour chasser ce
cavalier moi même ça perd tous ses
repères l'option des six bien d échange
généralisé 30.6 dame prend et mettez
maintenant enfin deux variantes va me
prendre des absents et 6 il ya plus d
attaques puisque les blancs contrôle
tout le food et s'était attaqué le
centre est aux mains des blancs
refus monter la taquinant là c'est
terminé donc ici ça ce n'est pas
possible donc après qui a aidé 5 et bien
stéphane les noirs sont obligés de jouer
cavalier frankie valli et là ça change
tout puisque ça va changer la structure
de pions on ne prend pas du fou et c'est
bien joué donc annoncé intermédiaire
foucan fou pour un fou qui attaquent la
tôle à la tour f 8 moyens question de
toute façon on n'a pas envie de bouger
le cavalier puisque ce fou et très fort
ce faux très fort il faudra par an et
maintenant on ne fait pas la faute on
prend avec le pian l'opion champions
pourquoi c'est important pour la
corruption et bien tout simplement
ici on obtient une très très belle
position on va jouer maintenant tout
rachat aurait pardonné le pion aux 7 ce
plan est arriérée finalement maintenant
il va être même s'il est encore dans le
camp des noirs il est sûre ça démange et
le pian 2 des 5 le maintien en plus
exact bien bien enfants corps et iossif
dorfman quand il commente ce genre de
position il dit dès que les noirs jouent
eux 5
on prend aux passants et c'est terminé
on va mater les noirs vingtaine - on va
mater les noirs parce que le roi va
devenir trop faible donc ici c'est un
gros avantage positionnelle maintenant
le danger pour les blancs c'est que les
noirs arrivent à monter une attaque à va
rester encore des possibilités il ya le
pion à qui risquent d'avancer
donc ça c'est le danger mais ici à
landas bien bien compris cette position
et il sait que les noirs n'arriveront
pas à passer avec leur duo de pions les
pions a et b et qui vont tôt ou tard
être obligé justement devant la pression
sur le pion aux 7 alors tibia cob la
moisson des pions qui à bondoukou à 5
pascal erre fort quand même puisque sa
menace de gagner un fou tout simplement
oui ça menace à 5 à 4 et ferme et le
four b3 et dans la boîte alors
évidemment si on joue des coups comme c2
c3 c'est pas bon du tout mais alors ces
trois ça serait une faute bien sûr
stéphane mais c'est certain avec l'idh
évident que le fonds peut s'échapper
l'idée c'est de mettre le fond c'est
d'eux dont le revers de la médaille
c'est que ya le couple icade dans cette
position qui évidemment va faire jouer
la tour s'est vite très efficacement si
on prend ces trois c'est horrible là il
ya déjà c'est déjà une catastrophe les
lignes commencent à s'ouvrir au tour du
roi blanc cepl but ces énoncés
présentent donc dans cette position le
coup subtil joué par à nantes c'est le
coût à 2 à 3 voilà
donc qui a l'air curieux mais on va voir
qu'en fait ça donne une
après ce qui va se passer ça va donner
une protection au roi blanc impeccable
alors que le roi noir va avoir des
problèmes
c'est sur le long terme évidemment c'est
le roi noir qui est au plus mal parce
qu'on va combiner la taxe sur la colonne
eu avec l'avancée des pions g et h
cette avancée étant imparable ou alors
très difficilement ici les noirs doivent
chercher quelque chose donc deux
possibilités soit on joue à quatre et on
essaie de jouer des cas d'après mais on
voit pas trop comment asseoir w4 on
essaie de jouer la carte à 6 ans joue à
quatre le football y en a deux
j'ai ensuite la dame blanche peut aller
en b 4 où on va montrer puisque c'est
les possibilités d'attac
il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de la
taille de pièces et si stéphane les
noirs peuvent pas attaquer avec leurs
pièces donc supposons qu'ils jouent le
coup à 4 1 4 11 x 2 puisque ans et
aménager la case et maintenant le
prochain coup des blancs c'est de jouer
dans b4 probablement dit vis way qui
vise par exemple sur d'anne decis déjà
d'un v6 cette menace rien n'a menacé ces
problématiques
on joue dame b4 éventuellement même pas
forcément on joue chez vincent et voilà
ça va être très dur de pousser des cas
puisque c'est que ces cases noires il ya
une raison qui fait que c'est très très
dur stéphane c'est que le coutour c4 est
impossible puisque le foie de contrôle
saccades moins cher que par exemple
supposons qui est tombé vite dans cette
position donc là je fais abstraction de
beaucoup de choses par exemple le pion
au sac qui est en fait tombé huit pour
l'idée étant que d4 et bien ajouté mme b
4 ici avec les blancs et on s'aperçoit
que les noirs ne pourront plus jamais
passé ouais donc le coup à 4 en fait
dans la position qui est celle ci ferme
complètement les possibilités d'attaqués
au noir moralité il faut mentionner le
coup b4 son admission mais qui a l'air
de l'autre possibilité car de perdre un
pion voilà on le prend puis on prend b4
puis on prend hélas probablement dans le
grand théâtre
et ici on voit pas comment les noirs
vont continuer leur attaque les blancs
vont jouer ses trois et peut-être revoir
ses deux essais les blancs qui vont
attaquer finalement de toute façon c'est
du blanc qui même en majorité
gildan même commencé à pousser leurs
pions voilà c'est dire que c'est un pion
pour faut créer des ruptures ça va être
difficile au nord de passer alors on a
passé beaucoup de temps sur cette
position pourquoi tout ça pour expliquer
que les noirs ne peuvent rien faire ils
sont dans la boîte tout simplement viser
55 le plan il essaye de jouer c'est donc
d'un v6 salaire un coup pas mal de dents
qui lui dame v6 avec maintenant la
menace entre guillemets b car oui qui en
cas de prix serait pas mal pour les
noirs là tout à fait des cats et c'est
l'idée des doigts alors tour à juin
contre attaque sur le pion recettes
ouais défense de tibias coffre et au f18
voilà est maintenant à nantes fait comme
s'il ne se passait rien il joue g4 voilà
il a estimé que les normes ne pourront
jamais passé de toutes façons de son
côté est par contre l'immonde son
attaque de notre côté il a fixé depuis
en recettes quand tu disais tout à
l'heure donc se mobilisent une tour la
défense est là on la mettra ses pions il
va démolir le rempart du renoir pour
pouvoir faire des échecs importants
stéphane dans cette position ne commence
pas par le couac 4 qui permettrait aux
noirs de jouer h5 ouais alors comme
alors pourquoi je dis ça et là c'est
simplement pour montrer qu'ici les
blancs ne sont pas pressés ils n'ont pas
besoin d'essayer de chercher de pêcher
en eaux troubles
il joue g4 les noirs ne joueront pas
simple c'est sûr donc là que font les
noirs et bien ils finissent par jouer
des quatre oui quand même
et maintenant il ya la défense steffan y
en a trois à quatre voies la ferme en
tout ils ferment tous voulu ferme tous
ces fermetures des portes donc tibia kof
cherche du jeu il joue d'elle ces cinq
menace a priori rien bah oui enfin ça un
petit oeil sur ces deux camps même si la
dame d2 et le four b3 partent les arrêts
dame prend ces deux matches ça fait
quand même deux défenses oui on voit mal
comment le four b3 va partir d'ici et on
voit pas quand il faut b3 parti rien à
mon avis il va rester là il va rester là
le peu de façon à nantes dans cette
position du roi bien mieux vaut prévenir
que guérir un mal en plus ça évite les
maths puisque maintenant il y aura plus
jamais maths c'est sûr voilà le roi
pourra toujours aller sur la casse à 2
et là en même temps au passage à nantes
lui dit voilà on regarde je joue au roi
bien qu'est ce tu joues toit et la
bastide yaakov ils voient ils voient là
la dame je peux pas l'admettre ou plats
halal à la cagade alors je peux pas la
dame je ne peux pas l'améliorer ouais
voilà la tournée non plus cette tour là
non plus le fou non plus bref je ne peux
plus jouer avec mes pièces donc soit
j'attends de me faire ridiculiser par le
pion à challandes wilkins atrache cinq
ouvertures et et matt soit j'essaie de
gesticuler sait ce qu'il fait
zhu de 7,5 et la dorfman éclate de rien
puisque il le sait c'est un coup
positionne allemand certains assez
positionne en perdant on prend aux
passants voilà ici on voit qu'en plus le
four b3 ce travail c'est la mauvaise
nouvelle
enfin il revient il faut donc l'éliminer
fou prend piontek l'adoption de
décisions prises mais c'est pas le c'est
pas le but
non mais cela s'est il veut pas prendre
un pion d'autant que stéphane que ça va
ça mènerait à une finale on va
compliquer le mentionner le problème en
nul après dame prend des six c'est une
possibilité trop bas blancs que le vent
fort et vous prend vous voilà dans cette
position d'un programme
c'est possible ouais et maintenant on
fait tout reprendre à comprendre dame
simplement ton compte à mouy c'est ça où
l'on prendrait d'abord la tour en
peut-être se séparer en fait ça revient
un peu problème est ici après option
prend b3 je ne sais pas ce que vaut
cette finale mais je pense que les noirs
sont pas en danger
à noter que s'ils jouent
donc bien sûr donc là beaucoup de
beaucoup de fautes aujourd'hui
ouais alors si si je tour prend tous ont
fait fou prend pions ces deux échecs et
ensuite on ramasse la tour comme le
rattraperait d'abord prendre le pion à
quatre avec un nouvel échec mais c'est
tout après est ici sur pions pour
enfants pour pro tour tout reprend et
c'est probablement nous montrent le roi
je pense que les noirs ont des peut-être
des chances de gagner
ils ont un pion de moins mais ils jouent
pas la solution ni chopin ce plan ne
joue pas le roi blanc et couper ici
légèremment taches noires
donc c'est un coup à faire finalement
variante assez longue on n'a pas envie
de prendre ceux qui ont des six c'est
pas dans le plan on préfère je me fou
prend feu
non non on préfère ne rien faire pour
faire 100 viennent d'emprunter la voie
là avec 4 on préfère ne rien faire voilà
h 4 avec lydie toujours h5 et démolir le
rempart de renoir exactement et d'ouvrir
les lignes quoi alors qu'est ce qui se
passe ici bas toujours à tibia cov de
jouer il sait toujours pas quoi faire
c'est ça qui est atroce c'est affreux
même
ah non deux continue son attaque dès
qu'il a un coût pour jouer il continue
donc il fait fort en fout tu comprends
et là tu en prends et leur fischer avait
dit qu contre cette structure notions là
on peut rien faire avec les noirs oui on
ne peut pas l'attaquer il dit si les
noirs arrivé en finale il gagne il
n'arrive jamais en finale
ouais c'est tout à fait vrai c'est vrai
ce sas et fisher qui disent ça en finale
c'est pas bon mais en revanche le roi
noir lui est faible sur le long terme le
roi blanc il va se cacher sont allés 15
à 2 et là il y aura plus d'échecs
possible
à noter qu'on avait commenté stéphane
une partie similaire c'était la partie
quatre chefs great choc avec avait des
blancs oui où cette fois ci c'était
quelque chose qui s'étaient quelques
cachets il avait fait une formation qui
ont de ce côté là oui mais c'est vrai
que c'était à peu près la même chose
avec leurs ouailles j et de quatre chefs
avaient rien pu faire c'était fait mater
à peu près de la même façon donc on va
regarder pour prend tour qui via coop
échange de pièces pour alléger plus ou
moins l'attaquent des blancs donc un an
ne reprend avec la tour normal voilà
tout à fait hélas les noirs essayé
d'empêcher les blancs de jouer eux mêmes
hashtag probablement web de toute façon
ici c'est délicat
il joue même âge s'est joué au même âge
5 à nombre
alors là c'est superbe c'est joli roa de
tranquille vas-y vas-y mon lapin ouais
je veux d'abord laurent à l'abri et
après je vais jouer
voilà exactement alors en fait alors que
peuvent menacer les blancs comme ça à
terme à terme à ce que peuvent menacer
les blancs bas je pense que la première
menace qu'ils ont fait dans cette
position c'est au tour 4 tours 4 avec
l'idée de venir en c4 1 et pour attaquer
à tour pour social monast aussi une
deuxième menace pour cette way avec
l'idée de monter la dame henri iv on
pourra capturer vos adresses m
donc il ya des plans dans tous les sens
et les italiens cercle et bien peuvent
ramasser tous les pions le roi c'est sûr
ne risquera jamais rien et tous les
pions sont moins à prendre maintenant
tous les points sont bons à prendre à
une seule condition il ne faut pas
échanger les dames faut pas changer
d'âme voilà sinon c'est la fameuse
finale tibia co-infection projet 4 on
reprend avec le pion f
mais ça ça va favoriser les blancs oui
salaires des délais blanc dans l'
attaque mais dans cette position s'était
fans que proposait que conseiller pour
les noirs fait un coude attente il faut
peut-être que les que pour voir ce que
vont faire les blancs un coup d'attendre
ça serait donc
quoi et je ne sais pas peut-être des 5
alors des 5 c par coda temps ça a pas
l'air bien c'est un coup responsables
des cinq mois c'est une possibilité mais
alors par exemple la pression pro hcc
pas bon c'est terminé mais c'est pas
bien c'est évident et ça ne s'est pas
bien il faut il faut garder le contrôle
avec la dame
oui donc il faudrait jouer on a par
exemple taxer cette alors autour de toi
je suis peut-être peut-être je crois je
suis un coup intéressant dans cette
position nancy fait dont le peut-être
torres 8 twh 8,1 fait beaucoup de tours
10 mystérieux validé s'éprend d'un g4 et
puis on prendre le virage 4 ensuite
white mollet ça ce serait l'idéal parce
qu'il peut se passer ici beaucoup de
possibilités peut-être les blancs est ce
que les blancs peuvent pas jouer
j'essaye quand même pas si claire
d'affaiblir la case et fils mais j'ai 5
c'est intéressant il ya tour c'est là
aussi un intermédiaire pour que ça dure
et on peut prendre la colonne c'est
chasser la dame de cette caste et 5 où
elle est très bien placé je pense que
c'est un bois m'allierai sur la base de
cinq coups sur un noyau place justement
la vente continue stéphane après être
quatre dans cette position un ris je ne
sais pas on va peut-être quand même
penser à jouer f5 parce que c'est très
chaud ouais enfin c'est très chaud mais
il ya un élément de persistant le roi
blanc totalement cachée le roi noir dans
les courants des marées c'est ça donc ça
c'est très délicat mais effectivement il
semblerait quand même que le coup joué
partie yaakov h 30 g4 et biens ne soient
pas ça sympa le meignen réel une réelle
solution tu en prends g4 et maintenant
tu auras schmitt tournage suit
maintenant voilà effectivement il va
gagner action ti gars comme il faut
prendre le plus riche car il menace
d'attaquer le pian h4 et puis les blancs
du mal à le protéger n'y a d'ailleurs
rien ne protège pas oui ce serait trop
passifs ils s'arrêtent pas de ce genre
de détails
jusqu'à maintenant ils jouent dame f4 à
noter qu'il faut mettre la dame avant la
tour c'est à dire que anne on a envie de
jouer sur la colonne f
mais s'il met la tour en f1 la dame
noire va trouver un très bon poste en
9,5
ouais donc ça il faut l'éviter donc
d'abord d'un f4 fait dans ce genre de
position le concept c'est d'éviter que
les noirs prennent des bonnes cases et
dont nous d'en prendre des bonnes donc
il faut pas réfléchir en terme de calcul
mais plutôt en termes de placements
pièces ici j'améliore la position de
madame sans permettre aux noirs de faire
pareil ça c'est important pour en
acheter un autre conte h4 pas mal
intéressant
touré fin réfutation tôt f1 leur attaque
attaque youtube 7 est aussi menace d'un
f 6 échecs des six échecs qui ramassent
alors un coût possible pour les noirs
c'est peut-être le jour le coût f5 f5
alors s'affaiblit encore plus ça fait me
met sa menace de récupérer le plomb g4
alors ceci si les blancs si noir par
contre récupère le pion pour rien oui ça
a l'air d'être dangereux pour lui même
parce que ça va suffire pour protéger le
roi et ils vont avancer si tu en as dame
mais si stéphanie lien est forcée il ya
quand même un match fort ces dames g5
attaque la tour au match 4 1 voilà la
tour pour le purger quatre c'est très
logique wayne il faut il faut prendre
dame cet échec est là où il va le roi
alors silva sur la colonne h
ils essaient mat très rapidement le
moteur action donc moi j'évite
s'efforcer et maintenant qu'est ce qu'il
ya dans cette position il fera chaud
quand même on me menace tour h7 stéphane
août suivi de dames et recettes ou
d'objets cette note est rien à faire il
n'y a pas de solution c'est imparable si
on peut me daems sonne comme une dame 5
d'accord c'est une solution 2005 alors
là comment ça peut se passer moi je
pense que je vais jouer le coup à fond
jour et de tous nos ventes lequel madame
m dames h7 suivi de tours c'est un qui a
l'air bon ah oui ça aussi d'un match 7
ouais non mais c'est vrai que cela
risque de porter maintenant tour c1 et
latour pénètre soit sur la 7ème
sociologie est à noter qu'encore une
fois que laurent blanc lui ne risque
rien oui les visas les noirs ne peuvent
pas contre attaquer non c'est vraiment
terrible ce qui se passe dans cette
position trois colonnes ouverte
une dame une tour ça passe ça s'infiltre
c'est complètement insupportable donc
dans cette position f5 n'est pas
possible c'est peut-être ça qui vient
comme à oublier en jouant tour contre 4
mais puisque dans cette position il ya
plus vraiment de solution il joue donc
le ku'damm 5 maintenant il évite donc de
perdre une tour d'un problème cet échec
mais là par contre voilà alors là ça
détruit complètement la défense des
noirs la défense qui n'existait déjà pas
mais on la détruit quand même ouais non
mais
il y avait quand même se plieront fait
ses pions faisait mentir un parcellaire
cola et il tombe le rempart croix rouge
cisco injustice et forcé tous
réussissent donc cela on entrevoit la
fin tout simplement en fait même si les
blancs ne gagne pas tout de suite il ya
des menaces à chaque coup et les normes
ne font que pareille menace
oui non mais dans le meilleur des cas
évidemment ce sera un échec perpétuelle
c'est à dire si les blancs ne savent
vraiment plus quoi faire et voit que les
noirs commencent à menacer de se
réorganiser et bien dans ce cas là on
fera chaque terre battue est donc
maintenant le coût humain énorme
quasiment forcé tout reprend j'ai
cravaché 4 tours 6 il faut déstabiliser
les pièces et demie voilà exactement ce
qui est fait par un an mais la dame rose
5 était très bien placé vallée protégée
par un mur bien voilà donc une fois
l'attaqué avec la pièce la moins forte
oui donc la bonde mg sept coups de
défense fall et bien on faire un un coup
de pub évidemment on ne change pas les
dames
non on repasse maintenant de l'autre
côté dames f3 l'attaquant la tour des
menaces qui commencent à arriver par h3
la tourette emprise bref c'est bien
horriblement difficile dam des quatre
jouer partie via cov maintenant
maintenant on repasse par derrière dan
f8
c'est terrible il y en avoir mais c'est
un tacle bien des six il y en a trop
vous savez si ce qui va tomber
ah non ne va prendre l'option des
cirrhoses passage quand même un homme
fait des menaces il en plus de temps en
temps il gones qui ont baissé il finit
par les gober tout cela il y aura plus
de défense puisque les pions même
servent à la défense
oui c'est assez important à mentionner
damas fuite échec rush 5 et hop on pique
le pion voilà ça y est moins un pion
j'entends donc dames 5 on revient sur
cette case qui est maintenant moins
stable dam des beats tranquille horrible
la dame ici est très bien passé
puisqu'elle contrôle ces deux cases au
tour de juan on empêche donc d'essayer
de fuir ouais et la menace directe et
tour des cinq sets et femmes clou en
adaptant la dame ouais donc tour g5
trouvé par tiga coffe ou pas mal il faut
ça protège le pion à ses hommes que si
on sait jamais donc là c'est affreux
des plein de possibilités maintenant la
pièce qu'il faut améliorer c'est la tour
ouais donc on peut soit là passez par là
soit là passez par là c'est au choix un
an de choisy tour des sa tournée c'est
être qu'un leurre bien quelqu'un qui a
l'air plutôt bien droit g4 ouais ils
essaient de s'en aller et maintenant on
passe de l'autre côté de toute façon
c'est vraiment dans cette position
stéphane une affaire de goût c'est une
affaire de goût puisqu'il ya vraiment
beaucoup de choses qui gagnent autour
des 1 dames e3 tour des quatre échecs
entre échecs et l'a même trouvé quatre
ses forces et bien il faut et c'est fini
alors là pourquoi il peut plus là il
peut plus défendre alors on va regarder
les cinq places disponibles pour le roi
ouais
ces trois là elles sont éliminés
d'office puisque à tour des trois qui
cloue la daâwa la clue ajoute la main
maintenant 3 5% que j'étais way
maintenant non damages suite madame h 8
matt d'accord donc ça c'est pas possible
non plus autre possibilité dans cette
position royal faisant un bref celle qu
il aille à une punition rapide également
tour des cinq tours des scènes qui est
là est ce que ces tours des cinq
d'ailleurs non c'est pas de savoir s'ils
ont besoin des ces menaces émanant des
s'impose il ya mieux dans mes fuite dans
la chute et tchèques
voilà la vérité chèque ça me compliquer
encore donc des répliques maintenant si
le roi bien sûr la case aux six dames
hobbit ramassera la dame
ouais roi aux 5 est donc forcé voilà
voilà
et maintenant c'est d'homme c5 stephen
comme ces cinq échecs et là c'est
vraiment terminé cette fois puisqu'on va
gagner la dame
ouais le roi doit venir soit sur la case
aussi ce sont les caisses des 6 et là on
fait tourner ici tour des six échecs un
long bras doit bouger et on ramasse la
dame et on ramasse la dame qui n'est
plus grande avec l'échec avec échec
c'est la pointe
c'est pas vraiment la première donne de
temps donnée la dame donc si on avait
les cinq as possible du roi et les
normes on espérait faire ce qu'on
appelle une forteresse c'est-à-dire avec
touré pions on peut parfois tenir contre
une dame oui oui avec toi puis on peut
parfois tenir contre une dame mais s'il
ya une difficulté supplémentaire
c'est bien de le bluffer un récipient à
noter évidemment enfin non c'est pas
évident du tout mais qu'avec le pion g6
c'est nul c'est à dire que s'il n'y a
pas de pions de l'autre côté moi ça
serait nuit voilà c'est ça serait une
forteresse on met la tour en f5 on
balade le roi sur ces questions c'est
quasi qui sont derrière le pion
on ne laisse pas la dame passé derrière
justement il restait plus à gauche c'est
important ça lire ci dessus à gauche ça
change tout ça change vraiment tout
puisque envoyant voyons en voyant une
bonne heure ce qui se passe comme une
possibilité roi h55 damache huit échecs
on va voir le plan des andes g4 et
maintenant d'alger c'est après demain
voilà à noter que ça devient très dur à
tenir parce que la dame est passé
derrière le pion normalement si le roi
est derrière c'est beaucoup plus dur
pour les blancs toujours au h5 damage
cet échec en 3g 4 et maintenant on
revient 3 b 1 voilà ça il faut amener la
pièce une marianne rouette une pièce
laisse le droit ne peut participer à
l'attaqué mais ici on voit que les noirs
ne peuvent pas faire la fameuse
forteresse avec la tour entre 5 3 et 5
puisque c'est donc changer si c'était
national plus de six tombes d'élèves cet
échec
c'est horrible on aura quatre dames f6
on attaque la tour et c'est fini
pourquoi parce que la tour doit quitter
son poste qui défend à la fois à
l'option g et le tournoi voilà donc
c'est plus rare qui va tomber un des
deux pions va tomber car par exemple ils
font tous riches est dur avec moi là je
crois à 220 go et maintenant quel est le
coût est bien intéressant qu'on pousse
le pion ouais c'est un coût possible
d'amener vite l'homme des vite enrayée
il ya peut-être un gain de tours
immédiat en plus avec tous les ans avec
qu'il peut y avoir
non je pense pas qu enfin si d'ailleurs
bon on va montrer le gain immédiat c2 r2
non non non il n'y a pas de gagner mais
je suis la grande les pions d'amd vite
mais c'est pas clair quand même parce
que les noirs vont pousser leurs pions
non mais c est très clair c'est fun
c'est très très clair que l'option
avaler vite quand même on va faire une
petite simulation élimination logique
car quatre dames prend 1,5 à 5 g iii là
les blondes ou pour mieux parce qu'il
est profonde et guin mathématiques qui
se perdent sur un échec
roy f3 donc là on fait quelques petits
échecs le roi dans eve 2 le but de des
petits échecs qui vont suivre ça va être
d'amener le roi devant son pion alors on
va regarder comment on peut faire dame
échec
on ne peut pas forcément moins f3 on va
faire un échec sur la colonne f pour
forcer droit à choisir nos colonnes on
est deux dames f5 échec
ouais donc là s'il vient au g2 c'est
presque tout simplement à une finale de
dame gagnante à la fin on peut prendre
là
pour prendre la tour on peut une fois
qu'on a poussé le temps et stéphanie si
soyons un peu sérieux et oui tout ça
voilà oui mais les noirs vont pouvoir
faire une dame aussi ils vont faire g2
ils vont faire une dame aussi mais oui
ils vont faire une dame aussi donc ici
c'est pas c'est pas très technique ce
qu'on a raconté non c'est pas si simple
mais les plastiscines ans mais ici on
joue d'objets 4 quand même j'ai quatre
échecs wemmel rouaroua f2 pour le roi f2
et maintenant on joue de cet échec
ici il faut revenir sur la case un
effort mois est tout à fait et là on est
tous le pion et laon pour structure on
gagne encore du temps à leur tour hlaing
arrive à trouver des on arrive à trouver
des choses qui gagne du temps tu auras
chien tout rachat on pousse encore il
faut encore plus et là qu'est ce qu'il
se passe on voit que si les noirs font
dames on prend et on fait une deuxième
daverat là on fait une deuxième dame
enfin bon là non mais c'est qu en l
occurrence ça s'est joint un temps près
mais c'est quand y avait beaucoup de ma
6ème pas gagné il y avait beaucoup de
gains possibles avant à noter que c'est
pas si simple à gagner donc revenons sur
la position finale stéphane je crois que
c'était
après le coup de 9 7 4 des 9 6 on force
les noirs a quitté cette caste g5 on va
aller piquer les pions ouais et ça gagne
très tranquillement enfin tranquillement
bon il faut quand même pousser les pions
bon ben voilà donc partis positionnelle
on va récapituler tout ce qui s'est
passé dans cette partie d'abord c'est
une ouverture aux dragons ce qui veut
donc dire la prison une attaque les
blancs ayant fait le bras ou qu'elle est
noire le petit une attaque avec des
recomposée donc chacun pour cent ses
pions vers l'adversaire
ensuite il ya eu ce fameux cavalli prend
cavaliers des quatre qui donc neutralise
la taille des blancs et simplifie celle
des noirs mais qui a permis à à nantes
justement était blanc de transposer vers
un milieu de jeu beaucoup plus
positionnelle et la tib lacoste s'est
retrouvé avec zéro en attaque à nantes
sur le long terme allait l'emporter
tiliakos a donc craqué au centre en
jouant un coup aux 5
ensuite après des échanges généralisée
on est arrivé avec une forteresse pour
le roi blanc et un roi noir un peu dans
le vent que nantes a transformé
évidemment avec la technique qu'on lui
connaît technique conduit quand on
connaît on ne peut pas attention on va
voir maintenant je crois qu'on va voir
la deuxième partie voyez la partie entre
vendredi et moringue et j ai mon rudoph
notamment la fin de cette partie
oui mais tout à fait on va aller
directement à la fin on peut la fin juin
on va on va là commenté très rapidement
à l'arrêt tout à fait donc c'est une
ouverture le donc du pur en dame
c'est ça ressemble à une défense lave
devant la dépense et 4 sél a slave à 4
c'est pour couper le plan c 4 du reste
c'est sans qu'une variante à la mode qui
transpose dans un grand vide à accepter
un peu curieux des 5 fu et 5 e 3 e 6
france et 4 donc là les blancs sont un
petit peu mieux évidemment si on prend
des cinq cavaliers prend des cinq
qu'elle et ses six dames détroit un
discours usé qui profite de la sortie du
fou s'est vite un peu prématurée parce
que leur immense talent ça on a un oeil
sur le climat 7 et en notes en attaque
le pion 17 way down 17 défend les deux
mais permet au passage stéphane
cavaliers progressiste qui casse la
structure de sion devra sa double sa
double les plantes 6 fou des deux vendu
alice or ces pièces tour g8 attaque
l'option g2 c'est pas grave poussée 3
ici on voit que ça devient très chaud
puisque ça m'agace tour des intrigues à
chasser la dame cette menace également
fou pour hexis ouais mais là à l'opium
jets d'eau étant prises mais purger doit
être prise mais c'est pas grave
grand roque sa série 6 est gonflé de
faire l'europe de ce côté un peu plus
faire de l'autre côté ce qu'elle est
quand même c'est bien ouverts quoi c'est
bien ouverts mais déjà la pression de
bronze est vite chez extrêmement
douteuse faut dire que morose à vide il
joue quand même des coups un peu space
mois il peut de temps du fou province
est gagne le pion à vii provoque tout
reprend g2 way cavaliers h4 fourchette
attaque attaque les relations j'ai donné
la touche 2 et le fou et le fou et est
en moi il ya des menaces quoi et l'on se
demande ce qu'il a vu on s'est compliqué
parce que la norme et puis laisser dire
que stéphane une fois qu'on appelait fou
il ya le fou et 7 il revient aussi à
wayne avec des matériels on va la
prendre et derrière un lecavalier 5
morose et vite chez eux mais le feu oui
c'est le cas de le dire de points trop
le choix on comprend pas bien ce qui est
en train de se faire faire un cavalier
en d3 échec probablement pourrait tout à
fait et alors à noter donc petite
remarque au passage sans essayer
d'éliminer ce qui m'a dit on se fait
mater viola pas d'amener deux échecs des
rendez vous donc on peut pas prendre le
car est donc on prend alors on peut
prendre la tour
il fut brièvement le vous devez lire
puisque ça une menace supplémentaire fou
au cices plus la daf et là on s'évite de
déchets canins trois échecs roi f1 ouais
pour preuve deux échecs
michel presse que matt way me ranger
n'est encore une case pièces de moins
pour morose et beach mais grosse attaque
quand même un gros s'attaque alors à mon
avis c'est complètement bidon je pense
que ce qu'il a fait est vraiment mauvais
vidon bidon c'est le mot donc puisque ce
retour pour un f5 qui semblerait que
vers la pièce et x 6 oui sur dame pro f
5 qui semblent heureux s'ils récupèrent
la pièce fouet 6 quand même méchamment
bref on peut pas reprendre nancroix mary
faut empêcher fois aussi voilà voilà
mais là bon alors c'est là que ici
bizarrement au vent de velits a plus ou
moins craquer puisqu'il s'est trompé il
fallait jouer soit calé j'ai trois fois
eu deux trois quatre
c'était deux comptages et le roi quand
il fallait revenir vers le roi g3 un
coup un joli coup d'attentes
à noter que de même si les noms et
prénoms effectivement une pièce de moins
la tourache a quand même ne joue pas des
tours à chaque joue pas mais bon une
pièce c'est beaucoup stéphane hocquet
cboe qui assainira bresse qui joue pas
c'est beaucoup aussi
d'autant plus qu'on voit pas comment les
noirs peuvent développer une attaque
dans cette position à mon avis c'était
complètement bien tout simplement tour d
un qui arrive qu'il va attaquer ce qui
est des trois avec la dame derrière je
pense ici qui avait pas de pas de soucis
devant le velly choisi d'investir après
une très longue réflexion
stefan wey non je regardais je l'analyse
de la machine qui avait pas l'air aussi
aussi catégorique que toi ah oui sur les
estimations de la position non c'est
possible mais bon disons
qu'intuitivement on a quand même
l'impression qu'il est une pièce de
moins pour pas grand chose ça il ya une
attaque de l'euro à leroy blank envers
le roi blanc comme qui coincé dans son
nom j'ai un fossé arrière quand même
dangereux que ce soit facile à défendre
c'est l'instant débat d'idées c
l'instant débat alors si vous avez des
avis envoyez les nous non moi je pense
je maintiens que les blancs sont bien
maintenant sa demande évidemment une
analyse précise et approfondie très
précises dont dame au cices on va la
jouer 1 3 une coup coût intéressant mais
permet tout reprend et cinq tours pro900
alors intuitivement qu'est ce qu'on
aurait pu se dire on aurait pu dire là
bas est très bien maintenant j'échange
les dames
ouais et d'un programme ouais et après
tu te reprends je vais vous aussi son
mec qui arrive du père une tour à une
qualité d'une qualité puisque j'attaque
les deux tours à la pologne mais ça
marche on m'a malheureusement il ya au
math tanger sept matches alors j'ai
cette note
ah oui ça c'est la mauvaise nouvelle
dans cette position après 3,5 on ne peut
pas échanger les dames on se retrouve
toujours justement le voilà je vois
qu'il ya des effets d'image qui sont
faits et je m'en réjouis
non ici on se retrouve donc avec une
position où les noirs ont récupéré leur
matériel et en même temps les noirs ou
continuer à avoir la taxe des fans
puisque effectivement il y avait quand
même de la table oui voilà donc h4 pour
éviter tout rejet cinq mois maintenant
là il le fit ni à la hache morose et
beach il a plus de pièces de moins et il
trouve un très joli coup qui va mettre
le roi plan dans une sorte de cercueil
ouais c'est le coup food et 6 et là on
voit que le roi blanc n'a plus de cases
puisque les deux là sont contrôlés par
la tour ouais la case age 2 est contrôlé
par le fou voilà et la 4g 2 va bientôt
être contrôlé ce qui est important ici
on ne voit pas directement quelle est la
menace mais il y en a une on va avoir
tout de suite et on for ski suisse qu'il
y a eu pour effet tourner maintenant
c'est fait vous l'avons fait vous
l'avait annoncé jean pierre merci à
proposer ce problème dans libération
d'ailleurs donc c'est bien de ça il y
avait combien de toi là où il y avait
une étoile une étoile est bon donc c'est
un problème pas trop compliqué une fin
pas trop compliqué puisque c'est matt en
deux coups m'attend de coûts voilà donc
ça passe par un sacrifice ouais tour g8
échec car ben bernanke avait un bizarre
parce que la tour est en prise voilà qui
est provoque l'abandon de mon pays ce
qui est alors d'autant plus bizarre si
on n'a pas vu l'idée ouais puisqu'après
fou prend tour il ya des objets 7 km à 6
c'est vraiment matin-là cercle voilà
c'est qu'il fallait faire échec sur la
colonne j'ai donc la tour fait échec le
fou en prenant libère la dame c'est
maintenant la dame qui fait maths
voilà donc on peut revoir cette image au
ralenti dans cette position il ya une
menace c'est tour g8 échec suite d'un
jet set matin s'il ya un a priori pas de
défense seul coup ça doit être d'un
programme on est tenté de se dire
d'amsterdam
mais il ya tout simplement tour propre
en attaque le fou et le faux pas de
casier si vous voulez manger s'il ya le
match angers 7 un email bon alors vous
lirez reprise pour mettre leur faut le
mettre en prison mais bon là c'est bon
faut le laisser en prison
on est parti avec une pièce de plus on
finit avec une pièce de moins c'est la
mauvaise nouvelle c'est la mauvaise
nouvelle donc ici vent devait l'y ont 9
et 10 qui souffrent dans ce tournoi à
noter qu'après cette partie il est bien
revenu puisqu'il a sacré peter blake au
oui tout à fait donc là on s'échoue
alors toutes les parties sont très
chaudes comme ça ça qui est ça qui est
pas mal on peut noter que shirov a fait
de très belles victoires tu parles de 7
contre timan voyez c'est le contre au
team très très technique
alors évidemment je crois qu'il a joués
tibia cov donc tibia cov c'est le
spécial prix de beauté donc il y en a
infligé un croquis at il joué également
alexei shirov sur le coup je ne me
rappelle plus mais en tout cas trois
victoires deux nuls
c'est pas mal avec ces chiffres en tête
du tournoi alors stéphane des pronostics
peut-être bon alors c'est un cas trio
qu'on avait déjà vu de sarajevo
parce que kasparov était à la poursuite
de hollande de adams et de chira of wine
notamment chez rock courtney adams est
sûre en fait utilisé est avec moi on
évite aussi dans le même tableau des
vestiaires craqué sur la fin et ben il a
fait trois défaites d'affilée juste
comme ça si reflux a fait une seule
défaite
sur la fin voyez votre obsession lui et
kasparov intervient les trois victoires
donc en fait ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que probable encore une fois ça va se
jouer dans les toutes dernières rondes
oui alors encore une fois dans les
toutes dernières rondes de jochen bon il
ya des affrontements phare qui se
prépare il ya des parties très attendue
notamment la partie à nantes cramique
ouais quand même partie qu'on a envie de
voir - le demain qui aura lieu demain
ouais donc un manque chronique ça va
être très très chaud puisque c'est le
champion je pense que les deux favoris
c'est quand même c'est comme kasparov et
cramique je pense d'assez loin pour
d'horizon ils sont toujours d'abord
numéro et de placement mondial pour une
semaine à pâques c'est un homme qui soit
disant il passé dans mon crâne nique au
dernier classement
non pas du tout non alors c'est non
c'est pas au classement elo où il est
passé devant chronique c'est quoi c'est
le classement c'est le classement le top
fi des le classement top speed et donc
qui ne correspond à rien puisque en fait
on prend le classement elo sauf pour
mais le champion du monde en premier et
le vice-champion du monde en deuxième un
ring donc c'est pas significatif c'est
possible le match de chroniques contre
castorf n'ayant pas content et on parle
aussi voir c'est surtout ça que anand a
gagné beaucoup de points c'est normal
oui on mal puisqu'il n'arrête pas de
gagner on lui vaut bien mais kramnik en
allemagne est encore plus critique on a
gagné encore plus mais alors à noter que
donc je pense que craig cathcart kramnik
parce que bon d'abord je pense qu'ils
sont un peu plus forts mais surtout
surtout quand même
ils ont eu besoin de repos voilà ça ça
compte énormément général en a eu que
quinze jours oui quasiment trois
semaines maximum pour ce pour se reposer
mais alors osez giraud pas quand même
quatre points sur cinq la surface 4
points sur 5 bat on peut dire que je
crois que shirov le problème shirov
aussi quand même c'est que bon il gagne
des partis mais il peut encore plein et
on peut on sait que notamment quand
kasparov il a beaucoup de mal il n'a pas
encore joué les gros et une remarque
quand même stéphane s'éclairer mesure
chirouf peur des partis et quand il
n'est pas en forme
oui quand il est en forme il emporte
extrêmement peu et on continue à en
gagner beaucoup alors il faut maintenant
il va sûrement une fatigue et je pense
qu'il va sûrement être fait et je pense
que la fatigue doit jouer de toute façon
je pense que la fatigue va jouer sur la
fin du tournoi vétérans c'est une des
questions à poser aux joueurs par
jean-luc chavanon ouais tout à fait pour
leur demander effectivement s'il pense
que ils tiendront la distance ou pas et
comme ça s'ils perdent ils pourront pour
un palais mots qui si l'on dit que
c'était pas bon effectivement donc on
fera le reportage lundi et mardi
ça veut dire pour la ronde 7 et 8 donc
ce sera exactement la mi tournoi on vous
fera le compte rendu vendredi prochain
donc avec jean-luc chavanon qui sera sur
le plateau qui commentera avec nous ses
propres images
donc ça c'est plutôt intéressant et donc
voilà donc ça va être un très beau
reportage pour cette prochaine émission
également il ya un autre tournoi qui
commence en espagne après linares qui a
été gagné par etienne bacrot c'est le
tournoi de obeyda way et donc c'est un
c'est les plus forts open pratiquement
une force de peines du monde avec new
york et éventuellement dans le chapelet
de parking à être il ya beaucoup de
joueurs mais il est moins fort donc new
york linares et ubeda à noter que
l'inhalation kung fu tous régulièrement
et peut-on affirmer s'il réunit les
meilleurs joueurs du monde mais c'est
pas ça c'est un très fort open avec je
crois qu'il ya toujours régulièrement
une quarantaine une cinquantaine de
grands maîtres donc ici etienne bacrot à
gagner qu'on finisse en effet un finish
canon de justement si ceni sur 7
stéphane c'est quand même à saluer une
telle performance du jeune français
qu'on avait tendance à oublier un petit
peu oui là il est bien revenu on avait
cru d'abord et après sa défaite qui
deuxième ronde troisième je sais plus on
pensait qu'il était un peu en dessous
mais non il revenu très fort retiennent
mac os très fort retour donc il ya
également au bédat qui va commencer
autre actualité dernier point de
l'actualité stéphane le match ponomariov
contre victor kornoi donc première
partie donc qui a duré une centaine de
coups ponomariov essayant de vis et le
victor le terrible le vieux lion n'y
arrivant pas victor tient deuxième
partie victor gagne avec les blancs une
partie de plus de 100 points ou encore
et la peau noire revient au score 40e
dans la troisième partie donc un ennemi
partout très très chaud voilà ben
wallace ou de leur qualité est au rendez
vous la semaine prochaine avec ce super
reportage mécanisée
et